This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today we're bringing you a story about something that wasn't thought about for years. Something that thousands pushed out of their minds that they were told they didn't have to worry about, only to have it come back to haunt them. It's a story from our friends at Planet Money. It's a podcast about economics. Possibly the biggest thing that we all collectively try not to think about, only to have it greet us at the grocery store, at the gas station,
这里是 99% Invisible，我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们为您带来一个关于某种被人们遗忘多年的事物的故事。成千上万的人曾把它抛在脑后，他们被告知不必为此担心，可它却卷土重来，化作挥之不去的噩梦。这个故事来自我们的朋友《金钱星球》（Planet Money）。这是一个关于经济学的播客。这可能是我们大家最不愿去集体思考的宏大话题，直到它在杂货店、加油站迎接我们的到来，
even in our homes. And this episode does a really great job of illustrating how massive forces pull at the economy like tides and create ripple effects in our lives. I am a huge fan of this podcast, and if you don't already listen, I highly recommend you do. This episode is one of our favorites, brought to you by reporters Chris Arnold and Robert Smith. One spring morning a couple years ago, Karen McDonough was having her tea at her dining room table. She lives in a cute little two-bedroom place in Quincy, Massachusetts.
甚至出现在我们的家中。这一集非常出色地说明了庞大的力量如何像潮汐一样牵动着经济，并在我们的生活中产生连锁反应。我是这个播客的超级粉丝，如果你还没听过，我强烈推荐你去听听。这一集是我们的最爱之一，由记者克里斯·阿诺德和罗伯特·史密斯为您呈现。几年前的一个春日早晨，凯伦·麦克多诺正坐在餐住房的餐桌旁喝茶。她住在马萨诸塞州昆西市一个温馨可爱的小两居里。
She looks out her window to the neighborhood beyond and she sees something unusual. There were like 20 cars and they all came at the same time and they parked like in front of my house, across the street, up the street and down the street. I just had this feeling like something really bad had happened. She was right. Something bad was definitely happening to her. And then I saw people get out and then they were like coming to my lawn and I'm like, why is everybody at my house? Karen puts on her shoes, goes out to the driveway. At this point, a group of men are milling around the lawn, casually dressed, except for one guy who seems to be in charge. There was somebody I think he might have had a uniform on or something, and he had a piece of paper.
她望向窗外的社区，看到了不寻常的一幕。当时大概有20辆车，它们同时到达，分别停在我家门前、街对面、街上游以及街下游。我当时就有一种感觉，觉得有什么极其糟糕的事情发生了。她猜得没错。确实有糟糕的事情降临到了她头上。然后我看到人们下车，朝着我的草坪走来，我在想，为什么所有人都在我家？凯伦穿上鞋子，走到车道上。此时，一群身穿休闲装的男子正在草坪上闲逛，只有一个看起来像是负责人的家伙除外。我觉得好像有人穿着制服之类的，他手里拿着一张纸。
And I said, what's happening? And he goes, we're selling your house. And I'm like, what are you talking about? He goes, don't pretend that you don't know what I'm talking about. And I go, I actually don't know what you're talking about. And he's like, well, we sent you information and it was like a foreclosure sale on my home. This made no sense. Karen had been in the house for 17 years. She's a registered nurse, makes a good living, raised two kids here, and she was current on her mortgage. Sure, there were a few bumps along the way. A long time ago during the great financial crisis she had asked for a modification of her mortgage. That
然后我问，发生什么事了？他说，我们要把你的房子卖了。我说，你在说什么呢？他说，别装作不知道我在说什么。我说，我其实真不知道你在说什么。然后他说，好吧，我们给你寄过资料，这就像是我房子的法拍出售。这完全说不通。凯伦在这栋房子里住了17年。她是一名注册护士，收入不错，在这里养育了两个孩子，而且她的房贷一直在按时偿还。当然，这一路走来也有一些波折。很久以前在金融危机大爆发期间，她曾申请过修改住房贷款。那
was perfectly normal back then, lower to payments. But now these men on the lawn were telling her this is a foreclosure. You are going to lose this house. Karen is thinking this has to be some kind of scam right? I mean maybe they're trying to rattle me. She doesn't know what to do, so she gets in her car. I almost didn't feel safe. Like, I didn't know what they were doing. And I said to the people, I said, I'm backing out. I said, get out of my way. And I just left.
在当时是很正常的操作，可以降低月供。但现在，草坪上的这些男人却告诉她，这是一场法拍。你将失去这所房子。凯伦心想，这一定是什么骗局吧？我的意思是，也许他们只是想吓唬我。她不知道该怎么办，于是上了车。我当时甚至觉得很不安全。就像，我不知道他们在干什么。我对那些人说，我要倒车了。我说，别挡我的道。然后我就开车走了。
For months, Karen had been getting mysterious phone calls from strangers demanding money, men insisting that they had dug up some long lost debt she owed. It seemed so sketchy, like some sort of con game, but the men in her lawn seemed pretty real. She eventually finds herself at a beach outside Boston. And was it just like you drove to the beach and like look out at the water and you're like, what the hell is going on?
几个月来，凯伦一直接到陌生人的神秘电话，向她索要金钱，这些男人坚称他们挖出了一笔她欠下的、早已失联的旧债。这听起来太可疑了，就像某种骗局，但她草坪上的那些男人看起来挺真实的。最终，她来到了波士顿外的一个海滩。当时的感觉是不是就像你开车去了海滩，看着海面，心里想，这到底是怎么回事？
Yeah, I was like shaken. Just like really overwhelmed. I was crying. It just didn't make any sense. I'm a mother and I'm a nurse and I'm being evicted from my house that I've been making monthly payments on and that I'm current with. By the time she made it back to her house, it was all over. The strangers on her lawn had sold the house out from under her. Hello and welcome to Planet Money.
对，我当时吓坏了。整个人不知所措。我在哭。这根本说不通。我是一个母亲，我是一个护士，而我却要被赶出我一直在按月还贷、而且信用良好的房子。等她赶回自己家时，一切都已经结束了。她草坪上的陌生人在她不知情的情况下把房子给卖了。你好，欢迎收听《金钱星球》。
I'm Robert Smith. And I'm Chris Arnold. We've been looking at a Karen's case for months now and what we found was much scarier than some scam. Karen was right. She'd been paying her mortgage every month for years. This whole drama was about old debt. Debt that hadn't been heard from in more than a decade.
我是罗伯特·史密斯。我是克里斯·阿诺德。几个月来，我们一直在调查凯伦的案子，结果我们发现，情况比什么骗局都要可怕得多。凯伦是对的。多年来，她每个月都在按时偿还房贷。这场闹剧的起因是一笔旧债。一笔已经有十多年杳无音讯的债务。
Debt that everyone had told her was gone and forgotten. Our investigation revealed that thousands of other people are getting the same calls and facing the exact same sort of nightmare as Karen. People who took out loans about 20 years ago, many say they were told the loans had been forgiven, but now the debt collectors come calling anyway. They are known as zombie mortgages. Zombies, because they can stay buried for years and then reach out and grab you. And take everything.
一笔所有人都告诉她已经烟消云散、被遗忘的债务。我们的调查显示，成千上万的其他人在接到同样的电话，并且面临着和凯伦完全一样的噩梦。那些在20年左右前贷款买房的人，许多人说他们被告知贷款已被免除，但现在催收人员还是找上门来了。它们被称为僵尸房贷。之所以叫僵尸，是因为它们可以被埋藏多年，然后突然伸出手抓住你。并夺走一切。
Today on the show, why are all of these old debts coming back to life right now? Is it legal? And is there any way to stop the zombies? Hello 99PI listeners, it's Sallie Helm here from Planet Money. zombies. shouldn't or what is Temu anyway? And another, what is with all the tiny soda cans about the surge in so many very precise smaller sizes in the grocery store like travel size, party size, fun size, kid size? Is it sneaky inflation? We get to the bottom of it and tackle more serious questions too. Check out the Planet Money podcast feed and let us know what you think. Karen remembers the first time she saw her future home, the little yellow cottage house in Quincy, Massachusetts.
今天的节目，为什么所有这些旧债现在又死灰复燃了？这合法吗？有什么方法可以阻止这些僵尸吗？99PI的听众们好，我是来自《金钱星球》的萨莉·赫姆。僵尸。不该买的，或者蒂姆（Temu）到底是什么？还有一个，那些微型苏打罐是怎么回事？为什么杂货店里会出现那么多尺寸精确的小型听装饮料，比如旅行装、派对装、趣味装、儿童装？这是隐蔽的通货膨胀吗？我们将探究到底，同时也会探讨更严肃的问题。快去看看《金钱星球》的播客动态，并告诉我们你的想法。凯伦还记得她第一次看到自己未来的家——马萨诸塞州昆西市那栋黄色小别墅时的情景。
It was 2005. She had just gotten divorced and was living in a small apartment nearby with her two sons. I saw this house. I really liked it. I thought the size was kind of charming. You know, it had a little yard.
那是2005年。她刚离婚，和两个儿子住在附近的一个小公寓里。我看到了这栋房子。我真的很喜欢它。我觉得它的面积挺迷人的。你知道的，它有一个小院子。
I thought it would be perfect because it was just the three of us. Back then, it had a little yard. I thought it would be perfect because it was just the three of us. Back then, a lot of people wanted to buy houses. The housing bubble was filling with steam. I had a friend and she was a realtor. And at the time, she was telling me that you could buy a home right now that it was a good time to buy a home.
我觉得它完美极了，因为当时只有我们三个人。那时候，它有一个小院子。我觉得它完美极了，因为当时只有我们三个人。那时，很多人都想买房。房地产泡沫正在不断膨胀。我有个朋友是房地产经纪人。当时她告诉我，你现在可以买房，现在是买房的好时机。
And here's how most people do it. To purchase a house, you put down 10%, sometimes it's 20%, in cash as a down payment. And then you borrow the rest of the money as a mortgage. Karen had a well-paying job as a nurse at Massachusetts General Hospital. Modest savings, but the house was $365,000 and she didn't have tens of thousands of dollars
以下是大多数人的做法。要买一套房子，你需要支付10%作为首付，有时是20%的现金。然后你把剩余的钱作为抵押贷款借下来。凯伦在麻省总医院担任护士，收入丰厚。她有一点积蓄，但房子售价365,000美元，她拿不出几万美元
for a down payment. But during the housing bubble, Wall Street and banks wanted more people to buy houses. So they came up with all kinds of ways to do that. And one was a system to get rid of the down payment. Instead of giving you just one mortgage, they would give you two mortgages, two loans. And that second mortgage would basically cover the down payment. They used to say, no down payment, no problem. Just take a second mortgage.
作为首付。但在房地产泡沫期间，华尔街和银行希望更多的人买房。于是他们想出了各种各样的方法来实现这一点。其中之一就是免除首付的系统。他们不只给你一笔房贷，而是给你两笔房贷，两笔贷款。这第二笔房贷基本上涵盖了首付。他们过去常说，零首付，没问题。只要再贷一笔就行。
And it was called the second because if something happened to the homeowner and they had to foreclose on the house, the big mortgage, the first mortgage would be first in line to get their money back. The second mortgage would be second in line. It takes longer to explain all this than it took for Karen McDonough to actually get one. It was the easiest thing I've ever applied for. I just filled out paperwork and submitted it and I was it was approved. It was $292,000 for the first mortgage and $73,000 for the second. The two-bedroom cottage is hers and she makes one of the great parental sacrifices for her sons.
它之所以被称为第二顺位，是因为如果房主出了什么事，不得不被银行法拍房屋，大额房贷也就是第一笔房贷将享有优先收回资金的权利。第二笔房贷则排在第二位。解释这一切所花的时间，比凯伦·麦克多诺实际申请一笔贷款的时间还要长。这是我申请过的最容易的事情。我只是填了些资料提交上去，就通过了。第一笔房贷是292,000美元，第二笔是73,000美元。这栋两居室的小别墅属于她了，她为儿子们做出了一次伟大的父母牺牲。
I gave them the master room, my room. I gave them because they shared that room and then I took the smaller room, but it was good. It's all good. And then as Karen sleeps in her tiny bedroom, the world just goes crazy. The housing bubble collapses and the great financial crisis begins. We were both reporters then Chris. Yeah, we covered this together sometimes, Robert, and it was pretty intense, right?
我把主卧让给他们了，也就是我的房间。我把房间让给他们，因为他们俩挤一间房，然后我搬进了比较小的房间，不过挺好的。一切都很好。然后，当凯伦睡在她狭小的卧室里时，整个世界却陷入了疯狂。房地产泡沫破裂，伟大的金融危机拉开帷幕。我们俩那时都是记者，克里斯。是的，罗伯特，我们有时会一起报道这个，当时情况相当紧张，对吧？
I mean, 2008, Lehman Brothers collapses. Banks were going under. The leaders of countries were scared. You know, it was on the news every night. And while that was going on, a lot of people were losing their homes. And as we all looked into it, we discovered it was those easy mortgages.
我是说，2008年，雷曼兄弟倒闭了。银行接连破产。各国领导人都感到恐慌。你知道的，每天的新闻都在播报这个。正是在那种情况下，许多人失去了家园。当我们所有人对此进行深入调查时，我们发现罪魁祸首就是那些轻松的按揭贷款。
They had this time bomb in them. The time bomb was that the interest rates were adjustable. I saw this destroy people. They honestly like shook my faith in the banking system that anybody would make these loans in the first place. Like people would be chugging along, paying their mortgage that they could afford. But after just a couple of years,
它们里面藏着一颗定时炸弹。这颗定时炸弹就是利率是可调的。我眼睁睁看着这毁了许多人。它们老实说动摇了我对银行业的好感，怎么会有人一开始就发放这种贷款。就像人们本来过着安稳日子，支付着他们负担得起的房贷。但仅仅几年后，
the loans were set to adjust way up. Yeah, and when you say way up, we mean like $700 more a month, $1,000 more a month. I mean, millions of people could not pay their mortgages. They were foreclosed upon, and eventually had their houses taken away from them. And it was so many people that the government had to get involved.
这些贷款的利率就会大幅上调。对，当你说的“大幅上调”时，我们的意思是每个月多出700美元、1,000美元。我是说，数以百万计的人根本无力偿还房贷。他们的房屋遭到法拍，最终被收走。人数之多，以至于政府不得不介入。
President Obama at the time, and his name was on the program, just because that many people needed help, there had to be this national intervention. Yeah, they were called Obama loan modifications, and they sort of pushed down the interest rates, essentially allowing people to stay in the place they were living.
当时的总统奥巴马，他的名字被冠以该计划，仅仅是因为有太多人需要帮助，所以必须进行这种全国性的干预。是的，它们被称为奥巴马贷款修改计划，它们在一定程度上压低了利率，基本上允许人们继续住在他们原本的住所里。
Yeah, I talk to people who would say, like, President Obama fixed my mortgage, and I didn't really have the heart to tell them, like, well, it probably wasn't the president himself who was, like, you know, moving papers around and fixing your mortgage. So Karen eventually got one of these loan modifications for her big mortgage, her first mortgage,
是的，我和一些人交谈过，他们会说，奥巴马总统修复了我的房贷，而我实在不忍心告诉他们，其实可能并不是总统本人在那里，你知道的，搬动文件并修复你的房贷。所以凯伦最终为她的大额贷款也就是第一笔贷款申请到了其中一项贷款修改，
which was just a huge relief for her. But you may be thinking, what about the second mortgage, the one she had taken out for the down payment? This is the crucial question that will eventually lead to those men standing on her front lawn. As Karen remembers it, her mortgage company told her that that second mortgage was forgiven.
这对她来说简直是一个巨大的解脱。但你可能会想，那第二笔贷款呢？就是她为首付借的那笔？这是一个至关重要的问题，最终将导致那些人站在她的前草坪上。在凯伦的记忆中，她的贷款公司告诉她，那第二笔贷款已经被免除了。
I was actually in my kitchen, I was cooking dinner and I was talking to a representative and he told me I would never have to make a payment again on the second mortgage. And I just didn't question any of it because I was so grateful that the loan was modified. And to be clear, there wasn't any reason to question it. The same company had given her both mortgages
我当时其实在厨房里，正在做饭，我跟一个代表通电话，他告诉我，我再也不用为第二笔贷款还款了。我对此没有任何怀疑，因为我太感激贷款能够被修改了。需要说明的是，没有任何理由去怀疑它。同一家公司为她提供了两笔贷款，
and now a representative for that company handling both mortgages was saying, hey, don't worry about the second. And sure enough, she used to get two bills in the mail for the two mortgages. And after a while, she just got one bill in the mail for her first mortgage. And that seemed to settle it, right?
而现在，这家负责处理两笔贷款公司的代表却说，嘿，不用担心第二笔贷款。果不其然，她以前会在信箱里收到两份房贷账单。过了一段时间后，她只在信箱里收到了一份关于第一笔房贷的账单。事情似乎就这么尘埃落定了，对吧？
I mean, this thing must be dead. Years go by, a decade. Karen keeps going to work at Massachusetts General. She keeps paying her first mortgage. Her sons grow up. You can still see the pencil marks on the kitchen wall. If you look at this, you can see like this is them growing up and like their height, we always did that.
我的意思是，这东西肯定已经死无对证了。几年过去了，整整十年。凯伦继续去麻省总医院上班。她继续支付着她的第一笔房贷。她的儿子们长大了。你依然可以在厨房的墙上看到铅笔痕迹。如果你看这个，你可以看到就像这是他们长大的过程以及他们的身高，我们总是这样做。
So that's something. Yeah, they are. They're both tall. In 2020, though, she gets a letter. It's from a company she's never heard of. First American National. It sounds like a bank, but it sure isn't her bank or even one that she's ever heard of.
所以这是个纪念。对，他们确实长得很高。不过到了2020年，她收到了一封信。发信公司是一家她从未听说过的机构：第一美国国民银行（First American National）。听起来像是一家银行，但绝对不是她的银行，甚至也不是她以前听说过的银行。
And the letter says, you owe us money. It had an amount and they wanted like a payment. And I think the amount was like $77,000. So I was kind of like shocked. I was kind of in disbelief. She thinks it can't be about her mortgage. She's been paying that every month to another company. So she calls the phone number on the letter. I'm like, are you the lawyer that's sending this
信上说，你欠我们钱。信上列出了一个金额，他们要求付款。我想金额大概是77,000美元。所以我当时有点震惊。我简直难以置信。她觉得这绝不可能是关于她的房贷。她一直按月把钱付给另一家公司。于是她拨打了信上的电话号码。我说，你是把这些信息发给我的律师吗？
information to me? And he was like, yeah. And then I was like, well, I'm like, why are you doing this? And he goes, well, why do you think I'm doing this? So he never answered me the way that I thought a professional lawyer would. So I just thought right away it was fraud. She decides to ignore it, but soon it becomes impossible to ignore. There are more phone calls demanding different amounts of money, threatening to foreclose on her house. If she doesn't pay up, Karen starts to piece together that these calls are about that second mortgage that she had so long ago, the one that she'd been told was forgiven.
他回答说，是的。然后我说，好吧，那你们为什么要这么做？他却说，那你觉得我为什么这么做？他给我的回答完全不像一个专业律师会有的态度。所以我立刻觉得这是诈骗。她决定置之不理，但不久之后，事情变得无法忽视了。还有更多的电话打来，索要不同的金额，并威胁要对她的房子进行法拍。如果她不付钱，凯伦开始拼凑出这些电话是关于那笔很久以前的第二笔贷款，也就是她被告知已经被免除的那笔贷款。
So she calls up her first mortgage company. I was crying on the phone with them, like having a nervous breakdown. And she says they told her, you know what, this is probably fraud. And they kept saying like, we're gonna help you, you can't lose your home through this. You can't lose your home through this.
于是她给她的第一笔贷款公司打了电话。我在电话里哭了起来，感觉精神都要崩溃了。她说他们告诉她，你知道吗，这很可能是诈骗。他们一直说，我们会帮你的，你不会因为这个失去房子的。你不会因为这个失去房子的。
That seemed logical. If someone official says that a loan is forgiven, then it must be forgiven, right? If no one sends you a statement for a decade, they can't just call you up out of the blue and demand money, can they? We called lawyers and advocates all over the country, government officials. They'd heard of stories like Karen's, anecdotal stories about people losing their homes or being forced to sell them to pay the debt collectors, but nobody seemed to know the scale of the problem. In fact, one top federal official told us,
这听起来很合逻辑。如果某个官方人员说一笔贷款被免除了，那它一定是被免除了，对吧？如果连续十年没有人给你寄对账单，他们就不能突然莫名其妙地打电话来索要钱财，对吧？我们打电话给全国各地的律师、维权人士和政府官员。他们听说过类似凯伦的故事，即关于人们失去房屋或被迫将其卖掉来偿还债务的轶事，但似乎没有人知道这个问题的规模有多大。事实上，一位联邦高级官员曾对我们说：
"'If you find out, let us know.'" Yeah, so we kept digging, filed freedom of information requests. In just one state, the state of Maryland, we found at least 500 people facing foreclosure from what appeared to be long, dormant zombie second mortgages just like Karen's. And when we looked across several states, we found at least 10,000 people who have old second
“如果你查出来了，让我们知道一声。”是的，于是我们继续深入挖掘，提交了信息自由法案申请。仅在一个州——马里兰州，我们就发现了至少有500人面临法拍，而原因似乎是长期沉睡的、类似于凯伦那样的僵尸第二房贷。当我们把目光投向几个不同的州时，我们发现至少有10,000人背负着来自房地产泡沫时期的旧第二房贷，而现在有一家公司正在迈出法拍的第一步。我们的调查还发现了一些数据库，里面记录着拥有这些房贷并正试图对人们进行法拍的公司名称。其中有第一美国国民银行（First American National），也就是凯伦所说的打电话给她、并用更多问题回答她问题的那些人。还有一些名字更加神秘的公司，比如BCMB1 Trust、FirstKey LLC和ARC私募股权公司（ARC Private Equity）。我们试图联系这些公司，但其中许多是在特拉华州注册的有限责任公司（LLC），这使得弄清楚究竟是谁拥有它们变得极为困难。但ARC私募股权公司却出现在了领英（LinkedIn）上。其联合创始人，一个名叫大卫·戈登（David Gordon）的家伙，在上面祝大家新年快乐，并顺便问问大家手头有没有想要出售的旧房贷。
mortgages from the housing bubble where now a company is taking the very first step toward foreclosure. Our investigation also uncovered databases with the names of the companies that own these mortgages and that are trying to foreclose on people. There was First American National, the people who Karen had said were calling her and answering her questions with more questions. And companies with more cryptic names like BCMB1 Trust, FirstKey LLC, and ARC Private Equity. We tried to reach out to these companies, but a lot of them are LLCs registered in Delaware, which makes it extremely difficult to figure out who exactly owns them. But ARC Private Equity popped up on LinkedIn. The co-founder, a guy named David Gordon, was wishing everybody a happy new year and asking if they happen to have any old mortgages that they
正如每个人都知道的，这是华尔街庆祝新年的传统方式。于是我们给大卫打电话，让他解释一下：为什么会发生这种情况？为什么所有这些沉睡的僵尸旧债现在又死灰复燃了？他很乐意和我们交谈。嘿，最近怎么样？很好。你呢？克里斯和罗伯特。太棒了。哪位是哪位？我们确实经常遇到这个问题。大卫属于买卖抵押贷款的整个生态系统中的一员。
wanted to sell. Which, as everyone knows knows is the traditional Wall Street way to celebrate the new year. So we called David up to have him explain, why is this happening now? Why is all this old zombie debt coming back to life? He was happy to talk to us. Hey, how's it going? Good. How are you? Chris and Robert. Excellent. Which one's which one's which? We do get that a lot. David is part of a whole ecosystem of people that buy and sell mortgages.
一般来说，有大量投资者将资金投入房屋贷款，会使贷款变得更便宜、更容易获得。大卫在这一切中占据了一个特定的利基市场。他在收购不良债务。现在，大卫并没有买下凯伦的旧房贷，但他买过很多和她一样的旧房贷，发信索要钱财，有时还会威胁要进行法拍。当然不是他本人亲自去，他使用的是一家债务催收公司。我并不是想夺走任何人的房子。
And generally speaking, having a lot of investors pouring money into home loans makes them cheaper and easier to get. David occupies a particular niche in all this. He's buying up bad debt. Now, David doesn't own Karen's old mortgage, but he's bought a lot of old mortgages just like hers, sent letters asking for money and sometimes threatened foreclosure. Not him personally, of course, he uses a debt collection firm. I'm not looking to take anybody's home.
我想明确这一点。但你知道，投资者理应收回他们的本金，你知道的，而且，这其中涉及真金白银。僵尸房贷的问题是在2008年金融危机爆发前夕产生的。大卫当时就在现场，亲眼目睹了这一切。他当时在摩根士丹利（Morgan Stanley）买卖像凯伦那样的房贷，把它们打包成资产包，然后再作为抵押债券卖出去。接着，人们开始无法偿还房贷，摩根士丹利也处于崩溃的边缘。
I want to make that clear. But you know, an investor deserves to make their money back, you know, and, and there is real money at stake. The zombie mortgage problem was created during the run up to the financial crisis of 2008. David was there watching it firsthand. He was at Morgan Stanley buying and selling mortgages like Karen's, putting them into bundles and then selling them off as mortgage bonds. And then people started to default on their mortgages and Morgan Stanley was on the brink
他预计自己随时会被解雇。我们在交易大厅里打了一个多星期的小型高尔夫球。我们都知道这是迟早的事，只是时间问题。房贷行业遭到重创。他们发放的许多贷款变得几乎一文不值。我们从摇滚巨星一下子变成了被冷落在办公桌前的人。
of going under. He expected to be laid off any day. We were playing literally putt-putt golf on a trading desk for about six weeks. We all knew it was going to happen. It was a matter of when. The mortgage industry was wrecked. Many of the loans they made close to worthless. We went from being rock stars to all of a sudden being frozen on the desk.
你知道的，华尔街今天宠你，明天恨你。后天就炒你鱿鱼。大卫突然失业了，但他注意到了一件事。所有那些他曾协助摩根士丹利打包成证券并出售的房贷，现在都在进行大甩卖。这家银行是一艘正在沉没的船，他们正在把一捆捆可疑的房贷扔进大海。抵押债券，好的坏的混在一起。你知道的，我看着其中一些曾被交易的债券，
You know, Wall Street loves you one day, hates you the next day. And fires you the day after that. David was suddenly unemployed, but he noticed something. All those mortgages he had helped package up into securities and sell for Morgan Stanley, they were on fire sale. The bank was a sinking ship and they were throwing bundles of dodgy mortgages overboard. Mortgage bonds, good ones in with the bad. You know, I'm looking at some of these bonds
也就是我们协助创建的那些。就在那时，我有了恍然大悟的时刻。这里有一个建立好生意的绝佳机会。这个生意的模式就是以有时几美分的白菜价买下这些房贷资产包。当然，其中一些是一文不值的。借钱的人永远不会还钱。但其他房贷可能还是有价值的，
that were traded that we helped create. And that's when I had the aha moment. There's a great opportunity to have a good business. The business is to buy these bundles of mortgages for sometimes pennies on the dollar. Sure, some of them were worthless. The people who borrowed the money would never pay it back. But other mortgages might be worth something
只要你愿意等待。而他们也确实在等待。大卫和像他一样的人收购了成千上万笔这样的房贷。不过我们向他问起了凯伦的事。她修改了第一笔房贷，并且她说她被明确告知不需要担心那笔第二笔房贷。
if you're willing to wait. And wait, they did. David and others like him bought up thousands of these mortgages. We asked him about Karen though. She had modified her first mortgage and she says she'd been told explicitly that she didn't need to worry about that second mortgage.
大卫说他经常听到这种事。人们以为他们的贷款被取消了。也许有时他们甚至被告知贷款已经一笔勾销了。但在许多情况下，他说，它们依然存在。它们并不是凭空消失了。我认为人们一直在场边等待机会，在某些时刻收回这些欠款。这就是为什么现在有这么多僵尸房贷死灰复燃的原因。房地产市场发生了一些重大变化，导致催收人员重新
David says he hears this all the time. People think they had their loans canceled. Maybe sometimes they were even told their loans were gone. But in many cases, he says, they still exist. It's not like they went away. And I think people were waiting on the sidelines to collect on those at some points. And that's why so many zombie mortgages are all coming back to life right now. Something big has changed in the real estate market that is causing debt collectors to come
回到了场上。这个重大变化就是房价。关于第一和第二房贷，最吸引人的地方就在于此。正如我们之前提到的，这两笔房贷就像是在排队等候还款，对吧？如果房屋被出售或法拍，第一笔房贷拿走所有的钱。剩下的任何钱才归第二笔房贷。因此，当2008年房价暴跌、房地产市场崩溃时，第二笔房贷看起来一文不值。如果你进行法拍并卖掉房子，你甚至拿不到足够的钱来偿还
off the sidelines. And that is home prices. This is the fascinating thing about first and second mortgages. As we mentioned before, it's like the two mortgages are waiting in line to get paid back, right? If a house is sold or foreclosed upon, the first mortgage takes all the money. And anything left over goes to the second. So when home prices tanked and the housing market crashed back in 2008, the second mortgages seemed worthless. If you foreclosed and sold the house, you wouldn't even get enough money to cover
第一笔房贷，所以第二笔房贷什么也剩不下。但如果你买下第二笔房贷，并在场边等待房价上涨，那么突然之间，那个悲惨的旧第二房贷可能就变得有价值了。房子的价值会高到让像大卫这样的人出现并说：咳咳，是时候偿还那笔被遗忘已久的债务了。这就是凯伦正在经历的事情。她在2005年以365,000美元买下的房子，现在价值已经超过600,000美元了。
mortgage number one, so there's nothing left for mortgage number two. But if you bought second mortgages and waited on the sidelines for housing prices to go up, all of a sudden the sad old second mortgage might be worth something. The house would be worth enough money that people like David could show up and say, Ahem, time to pay back that long forgotten debt. This is what was happening to Karen. The house she'd bought for $365,000 in 2005 is now worth more than $600,000.
全国各地的房价都在大幅上涨。随着这种情况的发生，越来越多像大卫这样的人开始买入旧的第二房贷并寄出催收信。这些僵尸房贷已经睁开它们冰冷死去的双眼，终于复活了。现在大卫告诉我们，他是讲道理的。他按规矩办事。他会与房主协商，甚至有时会稍微降低他所说的对方欠款金额。
And home prices have risen massively all over the country. And as that's happened, more people like David have been buying up the old second mortgages and sending those letters. These zombie mortgages have been opening their cold dead eyes and finally coming to life. Now David tells us he's reasonable. He follows the rules. He'll negotiate with the homeowners, even lower the amount that he says they owe just
我们在努力与借款人合作。十分之九的情况下，我们都在和借款人协商。而且大多数借款人都对此持开放态度。但他说，听着，如果你借了钱，你就必须还。你坐拥一套非常昂贵的房子，而这笔债务帮助支付了这笔费用，
a bit sometimes. And we're trying to work with our borrowers. Nine times out of 10, we're working with our borrowers. And most of those borrowers have been open to that. But he says, look, if you borrow money, you have to pay it back. You were sitting on a very expensive home and this debt helped pay for that,
帮助你买下了那所房子。如果有人不付钱或不回应，他确实会去法拍房屋。这世上没有免费的午餐。如果你申请了贷款，你就知道你申请的是什么。这让我觉得，这简直……你知道你申请的是什么。这让我……它只是……事已至此。
helped you buy that home. And if somebody doesn't pay or doesn't respond, he does foreclose on has-is. Nothing is free in this world. And if you signed up for a loan, you know what you signed up for. It blows my, it just, you know what you signed up for. It blows my... It just... You know, it is what it is.
事已至此。你知道你申请的是什么，没错。但在凯伦的案子里，她相信她当初申请的内容已经改变了，那笔第二房贷已经被免除了。当我们最后一次回到马萨诸塞州昆西市继续凯伦的故事时，她才刚开始接到那些感觉像骗局的电话。这些催收人员不仅索要她最初借的73,000美元。随着不同的电话和不同的信件，数字一直在变。就像，突然之间，这里是73,000。不，是77,000。不，哦，实际上是112,000。
It is what it is. You know what you signed up for, sure. But in Karen's case, she believed that what she had signed up for had changed, that the second mortgage was forgiven. When we last left Karen's story back in Quincy, Massachusetts, she was just starting to get those phone calls that felt like a scam. And these debt collector guys, they weren't just asking for the original $73,000 she borrowed. The numbers kept changing with different calls and different letters. Like, all of a sudden, here's a 73,000. No, it's 77. No, oh, actually, it's 112,000.
有一份文件显示，他们试图索取她最初借款金额的两倍半，即184,000美元。她再次给她的第一家房贷公司打电话。这家公司叫PHH。这就是她每个月都要还钱的对象。就是那些她所说的告诉她这可能是个骗局、让她忽略这些信件的人。他们告诉我不要跟他们说话。PHH告诉我不要再跟他们说话了，
One document says they were trying to collect two and a half times what she had originally borrowed, $184,000. She calls her first mortgage company again. It's called PHH. These are the people she pays every month. The ones she says told her it was probably a scam and to ignore the letters. They told me not to talk to them. PHH told me not to talk to them anymore,
不要透露任何信息，直接挂断电话，不要理他们。所以后来我就不再理他们了。事实证明，这完全是南辕北辙的错误做法。我们联系了PHH，他们表示没有找到任何记录表明曾给过凯伦这样的建议。甚至都没有记录显示他们曾告诉过凯伦她的贷款被免除了
don't give them any information, hang up on them, don't talk to them. So then I stopped talking to them. This would turn out to be exactly the wrong thing to do. We reached out to PHH and they said they have not been able to find any record of giving Karen this advice. Or even that they told Karen that her loan was forgiven
这回事。2021年，那家神秘的第一美国国民银行（First American National）开始对凯伦的房子采取法拍行动。他们走了惯常的法律程序。他们给她寄了信，在当地报纸上登了广告。他们最终在那个春日派那个穿制服的家伙站在了她的前草坪上。当时，凯伦正坐在海滩上，
in the first place. In 2021, that mysterious company, First American National, started foreclosure action on Karen's home. They did the usual legal things. They sent her letters, took out ads in a local newspaper. They eventually sent that guy in the uniform to stand on her front lawn that spring day. Well, Karen was sitting at the beach,
不知道发生了什么。他们拍卖了她的房子，最终中标者居然正是那家第一美国国民银行（First American National）。她的房子现在价值超过600,000美元。他们以180,000美元买下了它。几周后，凯伦在前门上收到了一张橙色的驱逐通知。我看到了那个橙色的东西，然后上面写着——贴在她的前门上。我看到了那个橙色的东西，然后上面写着——
wondering what was happening. They auctioned off her home and the winning bidder ended up being that same company, First American National. Her house is now worth more than $600,000. They bought it for $180,000. A few weeks later, Karen got an orange eviction notice posted on her front door. And I saw the orange thing and then it said like posted on her front door. And I saw the orange thing and then it said like, you have like 72 hours to get out. This is July 1st, it was a Friday.
你有大约72小时的时间搬走。这是7月1日，星期五。他们把时间定在星期五，所以72小时的时限，因为星期一是假日。我说，我有——这是7月4日。7月4日独立日周末，所以我根本找不到任何法律援助，尽管我一直在努力。所以在接下来的三天里，也就是72小时内，我根本无法入睡，只能开始打包所有的东西。
They did it on a Friday, so the 72 hours, cause Monday was the holiday. I'm like, I have- This is the 4th of July. 4th of July weekend, so I couldn't get any legal help, even though I was trying to. So for those three days, 72 hours, I didn't sleep and I just started packing everything.
你真的开始打包了？对，我连续哭了三天。我只是在打包。你在给律师打电话？对。大多数律师都说，听着，太迟了。我是说，女士，你的房子已经被卖了。我们无能为力。
You actually started to pack? Yeah, I was crying for three days straight. I just packed. And you're calling lawyers? Yeah. Most of the lawyers say, look, it's too late. I mean, lady, your house is sold. There's nothing we can do.
但她确实找到了一家法律援助律师事务所，一个同意接手她案子的团队。他们告诉她，听着，我们可以做——但她确实找到了一家法律援助律师事务所，一个同意接手她案子的团队。他们告诉她，听着，无论发生什么，都不要离开那栋房子。停止打包。不要搬走。我们要抗争到底。广告之后。广告之后，请继续收听《金钱星球》。
But she does find one group of legal aid lawyers, a team that agrees to take a look at her case. They tell her, look, we can do, but she does find one group of legal aid lawyers, a team that agrees to take a look at her case. They tell her, look, whatever you do, don't leave that house. Stop packing. Don't move out. We're going to fight this. After the break. More from Planet Money after the break.
好的。《金钱星球》广告之后见。好的，作为99PI的听众，我再为大家安利一次去探索《金钱星球》档案库的机会。它叫做“夏令营资本主义”（Summer Camp Capitalism）。这是一个关于某个夏令营的故事，那里的12岁孩子们对真实经济进行了深入的模拟。其中有心碎，也有成为前青春期少年所带来的所有其他体验。但在结束时，它也提出了一个关于资本主义与社会主义的重大问题。请在《金钱星球》的播客动态中找到它，并告诉我们你的想法。好了，言归正传，让我们回到僵尸房贷的故事上来。我看过很多僵尸电影，我算是个专家了，而僵尸最大的特点就是一旦它们复活，就会对你穷追不舍。
Okay. Planet Money after the break. Okay, one more pitch for exploring the Planet Money archives just for you 99PI listeners. It's called Summer Camp Capitalism. It's about a camp where 12-year-olds do this in-depth simulation of the actual economy. There's heartache and everything else that comes with being a preteen. But also a big question about capitalism versus socialism by the end of it. Find it in the Planet Money podcast feed and let us know what you think. Alright, back to the tale of zombie mortgages. I've seen a lot of zombie movies, I'm kind of an expert, and the whole thing about zombies is that once they come back to life, they are relentless.
你可以畏缩在家里，但它们会一直追过来。而且有成千上万个这样的僵尸。这几乎就是僵尸房贷目前正在发生的事情。不仅仅是凯伦，有成千上万的人醒来后发现他们的整个生活受到了威胁。就像对付僵尸一样，躲在家里期望一切会好起来是行不通的。你必须进行反击。有律师，也有愿意帮助你的人，因为这太不公平了。你不应该失去你的家。克里斯蒂·凯利（Christy Kelly）在弗吉尼亚州费尔法克斯经营一家消费者法律事务所。她不是凯伦的律师，
You can cower in your home, but they just keep coming. And there are thousands of them. And that's pretty much what's been happening with zombie mortgages. It's not just Karen, there are thousands of people waking up and finding that their whole life is threatened. And just like with zombies, hiding in your house and hoping it will be okay does not work. You have to fight back. There are lawyers and there are people out there who are willing to help you because it is not right. You should not lose your home. Christy Kelly has a consumer law firm in Fairfax, Virginia. She's not Karen's lawyer,
你可以缩在家里，但它们不断涌来。而且有成千上万个。这几乎就是僵尸抵押贷款目前的情况。不只是凯伦，还有成千上万的人醒来后发现他们的整个生活受到了威胁。就像对待僵尸一样，躲在家里祈祷一切会好起来是没用的。你必须进行反击。有律师，也有愿意帮助你的人，因为这并不公平。你不应该失去你的家。克里斯蒂·凯利在弗吉尼亚州费尔法克斯经营一家消费者法律事务所。她不是凯伦的律师，
but she's represented a lot of people who are in basically the same situation. Christy started out doing legal aid work during the housing crash 15 years ago. And like most of us, she thought this whole housing bubble debacle was over and done with. Ancient history, until a few years ago. She began to get calls from people who are getting these threatening letters about old
但她代理过许多处於基本上相同境况的人。克里斯蒂在15年前的房地产崩溃期间开始从事法律援助工作。和我们大多数人一样，她以为这场房地产泡沫的惨败已经彻底结束了。成了遥远的古代史，直到几年前。她开始接到人们的电话，这些人收到了关于旧第二房贷的威胁信。
second mortgages. You know, you see like a lot of scams as a consumer lawyer and I thought this can't be right. There must be something going on. And then I realized that this is not an error. It's a new trend. Christy calls the debt collectors and asks for the records on the loans.
你知道的，作为一名消费者权益律师，你会看到很多骗局，我当时想，这肯定不对劲。这里面一定有什么猫腻。然后我意识到这不是失误。这是一个新趋势。克里斯蒂打电话给催收公司，索要贷款记录。
And what she sees is actually really ugly. Some of the loans have no documentation, no payment history. The record keeping was terrible. And Christy was especially shocked by how cheap these mortgages are bought and sold for. Remember, these companies are calling up homeowners and demanding tens of thousands of dollars. But sometimes these debt collectors have purchased that debt for
她所看到的其实非常糟糕。其中一些贷款没有任何文档记录，也没有付款历史。记录保存得糟糕透顶。克里斯蒂尤其震惊于这些房贷的买卖价格竟然如此便宜。记住，这些公司打电话给房主，索要几万美元。但有时这些催收公司收购这些债务的成本却几乎为零。
almost nothing. We have a case where a portfolio of approximately 9,000 loans was sold for $6,000. And so each loan was sold for less than a dollar. Sometimes the loan sold for more could be 10 or $20,000 even for a loan. But in this case, it's conceivable that a company could purchase a loan for pennies. And even though it's called a second mortgage,
我们有一个案例，一个包含大约9,000笔贷款的资产组合以6,000美元的价格售出。所以每笔贷款的售价甚至不到一美元。有时贷款的售价可能更高一些，甚至可能是一笔贷款1万或2万美元。但在这种情况下，一家公司以几美分的价格买下一笔贷款是完全可能的。尽管它被称为第二房贷，
they can and do push ahead and take your home and get say $100,000 or more without the first mortgage even knowing about it. People don't understand, even very sophisticated people, do not understand that a second mortgage company can foreclose if you do not do something to stop it. And they can take everything from you. And it is just so wrong that this is happening.
他们完全可以并且也确实在推进法拍，夺走你的房子，比方说拿到10万美元甚至更多，而第一房贷公司甚至对此毫不知情。人们不明白，即使是非常精明的人，也不明白如果不出面阻止，第二房贷公司是可以进行法拍的。他们可以夺走你的一切。这种情况发生简直是太错特错了。
It may be wrong, but is it illegal? Kristi starts looking for things she can present to a judge and get these foreclosures stopped. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing.
这可能是错的，但它是非法的吗？克里斯蒂开始寻找她可以提交给法官、并藉此叫停这些法拍的证据。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。
I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I'm not sure was like another panic. Like there's no protections. You know, my client thought their loan had been canceled or forgiven, but there's no database of like all the loans that are canceled or forgiven so you can go and verify it. So it's hard to prove that the loan was canceled.
我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。我不知道这是一件好事还是一件坏事。感觉就像又一场恐慌。就像没有任何保障。你知道的，我的客户以为他们的贷款已经被取消或免除了，但并没有一个包含所有已被取消或免除贷款的数据库，供你去核实。所以很难证明这笔贷款确实被取消了。
But Christy notices something that the debt collectors might have overlooked. A huge thing actually that they had either missed or ignored in the regulations. Something that she thinks she might be able to fight them on. We told you about how the debt collectors have added years and years worth of interest and late fees to the debt, sometimes doubling the size of the loan. Federal regulations say you can do that, but here's the catch. You have to send monthly statements, like the ones you get for credit cards and student debt. Regulation Z, which is part of the Truth in Lending Act. It requires monthly statements be sent
但克里斯蒂注意到了一点，这是催收人员可能忽视的地方。实际上是一个巨大的漏洞，他们在规章制度中要么漏掉了要么忽略了这一点。她认为自己或许可以利用这一点与他们对抗。我们之前告诉你，催收人员是如何在债务上叠加了长达多年之久的利息和滞纳金的，有时甚至让贷款规模翻倍。联邦法规规定你可以这样做，但问题来了。你必须发送月度对账单，就像你收到的信用卡和学生贷款对账单那样。《Z条例》（Regulation Z），它是《诚实借贷法》（Truth in Lending Act）的一部分。它规定如果房贷产生了利息，
if there is interest assessed on a mortgage. Did you say Regulation Z? Z like zombie? Yes, exactly like zombie. I love it. Fighting zombies with Yes. Exactly like zombie. I love it. Fighting zombies with zombies. Regulation Z. Christy now had her legal crossbow to take on the zombie mortgages. In court she can now ask these debt collectors, oh, one more thing. Before you foreclose on this home and take away everything from this person, show me
就必须发送月度对账单。你刚才说的是Z条例吗？Z就像僵尸（Zombie）那个Z？是的，完全就像僵尸。我太喜欢了。用僵尸对抗僵尸。Z条例。克里斯蒂现在有了对付僵尸房贷的法律重弩。在法庭上，她现在可以质问这些催收人员：“哦，还有一件事。在你们对这栋房子进行法拍并夺走这个人的所有财产之前，请把这10年来的对账单拿给我看。”我想看到每一个月、每一张对账单，上面列出每一次漏掉的还款、每一分钱的利息。
the 10 years worth of statements, please. I want to see every month, every statement with every mispayment, every dime of interest. this home and take away everything from this person, show me the 10 years worth of statements, please. I want to see every month, every statement with every mispayment, every dime of interest. But she says a lot of the time that just never happened. The homeowners hadn't been getting any statements for years and then the companies would pile on a massive amount of interest in late fees retroactively.
但她说，很多时候这种情况根本没有发生。房主多年来没有收到任何对账单，然后这些公司就会追溯性地堆积巨额的利息和滞纳金。
In some ways, the greed of the second mortgage holders has given people leverage in their cases because it's just not good enough to collect the value of the note and they wanna go and get every last dollar and take every dime of equity. They then open themselves up to serious legal consequences and provide consumers the leverage
在某些方面，第二房贷持有者的贪婪反倒在案件中赋予了人们谈判的筹码，因为仅仅收回票面价值对他们来说根本不够，他们想要榨干最后一美元，夺走每一分钱的资产净值。这随之让他们自己暴露在严重的法律后果之下，并为消费者提供了谈判的筹码。
they need to stay in their homes. As a lawyer, Christie can say, gotcha, you violated regulation Z on sending statements. So your claim against my client is completely bogus. This is just one strategy, but Christie has used it to help homeowners in dozens of cases. She just resolved a class action case where she was able to get the names of nearly 300 homeowners from one company and help them all. Still, she's just one lawyer basically in a lifeboat trying to pull in all the people she can to rescue them,
他们需要留在自己的家里。作为一名律师，克里斯蒂可以指出：抓到你了，你在发送对账单时违反了Z条例。所以你对我当事人的索赔完全是无稽之谈。这只是策略之一，但克里斯蒂用它帮助了数十起案件中的房主。她刚刚解决了一起集体诉讼，通过该诉讼，她获取了一家公司近300名房主的名单并帮助了他们所有人。不过，她基本上只是救生艇上的一个律师，试图把所有能拉上船的人都拉上来拯救他们，
but knowing that there must be thousands more out there who need help. Among them, Karen McDonough, back in Quincy, Massachusetts. Hey, Karen. Oh, yeah. Good to see you again. You too. Despite everything that has happened, Karen is still in her little yellow house. We sat down with her in her living room and she explained what had happened over the last few years.
但她知道外面肯定还有成千上万需要帮助的人。其中就包括马萨诸塞州昆西市的凯伦·麦克多诺。嘿，凯伦。哦，是的。很高兴再次见到你。我也是。尽管发生了这一切，凯伦仍然住在她那栋黄色的小房子里。我们在她的客厅里坐下来，她向我们讲述了过去几年里发生的事情。
She got a team of lawyers, she stopped packing her boxes and did not move out. The eviction proceedings are on hold while they argue the case in court. First, American National legally owns the place, but Karen's still paying her mortgage every month. So she's living in this kind of limbo. I feel like what happened was a terrible thing. But I'm still, like, really hopeful
她找了一支律师团队，停止了打包行李，没有搬走。在法庭辩论案件期间，驱逐程序被搁置了。首先，美利坚国民银行在法律上拥有这个地方，但凯伦每个月仍在支付房贷。所以她处于这种不上不下的 limbo（悬而未决）状态。我觉得发生的事情是一件可怕的事。但我仍然，呃，真的充满希望
that I'm going to stay in my home. I'm really hopeful I'm going to win this case. We'll have to wait and see. At one point, these zombie seconds were real loans. And in some cases, the debt collectors have a legitimate claim to collect or foreclose on people's homes. In other cases, they don't. They haven't followed a bunch of rules.
希望我能留在我的家里。我真的希望我能赢得这场官司。我们只能拭目以待。在某个时间点，这些僵尸二胎房贷确实是真正的贷款。在某些情况下，收债人对催收或对人们的房屋进行止赎拥有合法的索赔权。但在其他情况下，他们没有。他们没有遵守一堆规则。
Where all that stands with Karen's case is still playing out. Karen's lawyers have now been piecing together what happened to that second mortgage over the past 12 years. And it's kind of amazing, really. She spent 10 minutes signing a mortgage and then it took on a life of its own that she never knew about. Karen has filed a lawsuit that lays out the story we just heard. That she was allegedly told the second mortgage was forgiven, that she didn't get statements, and that she was told the debt collection was probably
凯伦的案件最终会如何发展仍在进行中。凯伦的律师现在一直在拼凑过去12年里那笔第二顺位抵押贷款究竟发生了什么。说实话，这真是有点不可思议。她花了10分钟签署了一份抵押贷款，然后它就有了它自己的一段生命，而这是她从未预料到的。凯伦提起了一项诉讼，陈述了我们刚才听到的故事。据称她被告知第二顺位抵押贷款已被免除，她没有收到对账单，并且她被告知催收债务可能是
fraud. Her lawyers are arguing that the mortgage should have been resolved a decade ago. Instead, when her lawyers tracked her second mortgage, they found that it got passed from company to company and it eventually was sold in a huge batch of about 600 other mortgages in 2020 to an LLC apparently connected to First American National, which her lawsuit alleges used unfair and deceptive practices to foreclose on her house. And who exactly is this First American National? Despite a name that sounds like a bank, it is no bank. Far from it. It appears to be a small outfit run by a guy named Ira Bailey out of New Jersey. He didn't agree to an interview with us, but he said in email he's been doing this for 21 years. And in a court document, the company disputed Karen's description of their interactions,
欺诈。她的律师辩称，这笔抵押贷款本应在十年前就得到解决。相反，当她的律师追踪她的第二顺位抵押贷款时，他们发现它被一家接一家公司转手，最终在2020年被打包成大约600笔其他抵押贷款的大宗交易，出售给了一家显然与美利坚国民银行有关联的有限责任公司（LLC）。诉讼称该公司使用了不公平和欺骗性手段对她的房子进行止赎。这个美利坚国民银行到底是谁？尽管它的名字听起来像是一家银行，但它根本不是银行。远非如此。它似乎是由一个名叫艾拉·贝利的人在新泽西州经营的一家小型机构。他不同意接受我们的采访，但他在电子邮件中表示，他干这一行已经21年了。在一份法庭文件中，该公司对凯伦关于他们互动的描述提出了异议，
denied any allegations of wrongdoing. And check this out. Once Karen's lawyers looked into First American National, they found something else. A state banking regulator had sanctioned the company for operating as an unlicensed debt collector. First American didn't admit wrongdoing, but it was fined by the state in order to stop. Karen's lawyers alleged that it then foreclosed on Karen's house anyway, in violation of that agreement. I'm not really clear like why these people were able to foreclose when they weren't even supposed to be practicing in the state because of their history of what they've been doing.
否认了任何不当行为的指控。不仅如此。一旦凯伦的律师对美利坚国民银行进行调查，他们就发现了别的东西。一个州银行业监管机构曾对该公司进行制裁，因为该公司作为无证收债人运营。美利坚国民银行没有承认违规，但它被州政府罚款并被勒令停止。凯伦的律师称，随后该公司仍然对凯伦的房子进行了止赎，违反了该协议。我真的不明白为什么这些人能够进行止赎，因为他们过去的所作所为，按理说他们甚至根本不应该在该州执业。
Buying a home is the biggest financial decision that most people ever make. Hundreds of thousands of dollars in a loan backed by the place that we live and sleep every night. That's why after the housing bubble collapsed, the government worked really hard to try to keep people in their homes and also to try to fix the system. New laws were passed, mortgages were modified,
买房是大多数人一生中做出的最大财务决定。贷款金额高达数十万美元，并以我们每晚居住和睡觉的地方作为担保。这就是为什么在房地产业泡沫破裂后，政府付出了巨大努力，试图让人们留在自己的家里，同时也试图修复这个系统。新的法律出台了，抵押贷款被修改了，
and everyone moved on. But now we're seeing that there's one more thing that hasn't been fixed. And that's that people like Karen, the survivors of that financial crisis, who managed to keep their homes 15 years ago, those same people's homes are now being threatened all over again. Thousands of them. And what can you do as a homeowner like Karen, other than fight it in court?
每个人都继续前行。但现在我们看到，还有一件事没有得到修复。那就是像凯伦这样的人——那场金融危机的幸存者，他们在15年前设法保住了自己的房子——这些同样的人的房子现在又一次面临威胁。成千上万的人。作为一个像凯伦这样的房主，除了在法庭上抗争，你还能做什么？
Beg your public officials to do something and just try to keep your life together. I noticed when I came in, like your yard is clean, you have like a basket of like lovely purple flowers. Pansies, is that what they're? Yeah. You don't technically own this house anymore. It's still my house. Like it's on principle.
恳求你的公职人员做点什么，并努力维持你的生活。我注意到我进来时，比如你的院子很整洁，你有一篮子像样的紫色花朵。三色堇，是那种吗？是的。你从技术上讲不再拥有这房子了。这仍然是我的房子。就凭原则。我仍在付款。是的，我没有，但是——你仍然在打扫院子，你仍在修剪草坪。是的，就凭原则。我仍在付款。是的，我没有，但是——你仍在打扫院子。你仍在修剪草坪。是的，这仍然是我的家。那是克里斯·阿诺德和罗伯特·史密斯。有关这个故事的更多信息，他们有一篇数字报道，里面有更深入的报道
I'm still making payments. Yeah, I don't, but- You're still cleaning the yard, you're still mowing the lawn. Yeah, it's on principle. I'm still making payments. Yeah, I don't, but- You're still cleaning the yard. You're still mowing the lawn. Yeah, it's still my home. That was Chris Arnold and Robert Smith. For more on this story, they have a digital piece with further reporting
关于来自NPR调查团队的僵尸抵押贷款。你可以在 npr.org slash zombie 上找到它。本集由萨姆·黄马·凯斯勒制作，杰丝·姜剪辑，鲍勃·利尔提供帮助。事实核查由西拉·华雷斯完成，罗伯特·罗德里格斯负责工程技术，帕特里克·穆雷协助。亚历克斯·戈德马克是《星球金钱》的执行制作人。如果你还没有订阅《星球金钱》，我强烈建议你订阅。
on zombie mortgages from NPR's investigations team. You can find it at npr.org slash zombie. This episode was produced by Sam Yellowhorse Kessler and edited by Jess Jang with help from Bob Little. It was fact-checked by Sierra Juarez, engineering by Robert Rodriguez with an assist from Patrick Murray. Alex Goldmark is Planet Money's executive producer. If you haven't already subscribed to Planet Money, I highly recommend you do.
他们的许多节目真正深入探讨了我们在99PI上喜欢谈论的一些事情，即塑造我们世界的看不见的力量。有一集探讨了为什么某家公司在设计界对颜色有一种垄断，或者为什么坐飞机感觉比半个世纪前糟糕得多，或者为什么苏打水罐似乎变得越来越小。如果你想更好地了解你周围的世界，这是一个绝佳的收听选择。你在哪里收听播客，就去哪里订阅《星球金钱》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
A lot of their episodes really dig into some of the stuff that we love talking about on 99PI, the unseen forces that shape our world. There's an episode about why one company has a sort of monopoly on colors in the design world, or why flying a plane feels like it's way worse than it was a half century ago, or why soda cans seem to be getting smaller and smaller. It's a great listen if you want to better understand the world around you. Subscribe to Planet Money wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们的许多节目确实深入探讨了我们在 99PI 上喜欢讨论的一些内容，即塑造我们世界的看不见的力量。有一集节目讲述了为什么一家公司在设计界对颜色具有某种垄断地位，或者为什么坐飞机感觉比半个世纪前糟糕得多，或者为什么易拉罐似乎变得越来越小。如果你想更好地了解你周围的世界，这是一个非常棒的节目。在您获取播客的任何地方订阅 Planet Money。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。